Welcome to toxic Google.
I'm Alan Moss.
I'm vice president of sales and operations here in it is my distinct pleasure to
welcome Leslie Berlin to toxic Google.
Thank you.
Leslie is the author of the recently published book,
troublemakers Silicon Valley's coming of age.
Her first book was the man behind the microchip,
Robert Noise in the invention of Silicon Valley.
She is project historian for the Silicon Valley Archives at Stanford University
and she's been a columnist for the New York Times and commented on technology
and Silicon Valley for the Wall Street Journal,
NPR,
BBC,
the Atlantic PBS wire.
Do you get it?
So really thrilled to have Leslie today and a host,
a conversation on her knee book.
So what we'll do is,
um,
I'll have an opportunity to,
talk a bit and,
and have this conversation with Leslie and then we'll open it up to your,
your questions.
Um,
conglomerates are usually not bashful and we have a mic here and,
um,
special inducement,
particularly good questions.
So we'll also come with a buck,
a copy of your own.
Uh,
welcome,
Leslie.
Great to have you here.
Thank you.
Um,
so,
uh,
where to start,
um,
in troublemakers you chronicle seven individuals who were in the technology
space,
the very early days of 1969 to about 1984.
Um,
and their contributions to not only founding new industries and video gaming,
personal computing,
biotechnology,
and many more,
many more.
How did you choose to,
to focus on these individuals?
Well,
the first thing I did was I put together a timeline of silicon valley history
just with a dot for each kind of significant event.
And in this period between 1969 in 1976,
the,
the density of dots,
what's unmatched anywhere because you had the founding of apple,
Genentech,
Atari,
Kleiner Perkins,
sequoia capital,
you're the first arpanet transmission that turns into the Internet.
You had the birth of the independent software business,
you had the,
the invention of the microchip,
the microprocessor.
And it was,
uh,
like watching.
It was like watching the big bang,
basically just,
uh,
because before this time silicon valley was like this regional backwater wasn't
even called Silicon Valley and,
d,
it was sort of existed around one industry,
which was microchips is semi conductors.
And it was gearheads selling to gearheads.
And at the end of really,
if you just look at the first seven years,
you have personal computing and video games.
So you have the first really kind of high tech consumer electronics,
making it out into the world,
microprocessor,
consumer electronics,
you have the biotech industry being born and modern venture cap.
It was crazy to see what had happened.
And then I was trying to figure out,
well how on earth do you tell a story that has this complicated?
And I decided that the answer had to be that you had to find good people to tell
the story through because I don't know how many of you have ever sat through a
reading about the invention of a particular piece of technology and that can be
kind of dry.
And whereas I,
I think that the stories of how people did it and sometimes how they failed to
do it are very interesting.
So my criteria were three.
I wanted to find people who were largely unknown.
That was really important to me.
Um,
so this is why when I write about apple,
for example,
I don't write about jobs and I don't write about Wazniak.
I mean they are both peripheral characters next to the person who's my main
focus,
who is Mike Markkula.
And,
um,
most people don't know about Mike,
but Mike owned a third of apple along with jobs and was when they started the
company.
And he was the guy who came to the famous garage in Cupertino and saw these two
guys who,
I mean,
jobs was 21 was,
was a few years older jobs would have loved to figure out how to start a
company.
But I mean,
he had 17 months of business experience in his entire life and that was as a
tech for Atari was,
would've been happy to stay at HP forever and ever.
Um,
as,
as an engineer.
As a matter of fact,
he tried to sell the Apple Watch.
He tried to give the apple one to HP and they didn't want it.
So,
uh,
I,
I would,
I knew that there were tons and tons of these little companies,
these little a personal computer want to be companies in what we now call
silicon valley in places like Albuquerque.
So what was it that was special about this company?
Because they all had a job Zn type,
not as brilliant as Steve Jobs.
They all had a,
was Anakin type,
not as brilliant as was perhaps,
but none of them had a Mike Markkula and Mike had retired from Intel.
He'd gotten there before the IPO.
He had watched this little bitty company that was in,
you know,
another company's cast off space,
grow into what it became.
And he knew how to,
how to turn this idea.
He saw,
which was the apple too,
into what apple became,
which was the youngest company ever to make it into the fortune 500.
So I wanted to tell the stories of those people whose roles were so important,
but nobody knew thems.
And,
um,
what inspired it actually was I was at a party and,
uh,
at this party was the COO of a company that has a superstar CEO and COO started
singing a little song and the song's only words where I did all the work.
He got all the credit and I thought,
you know,
the,
for all the people in the spotlight,
even the people who deserve to be in the spotlight,
there are so many people who are just outside the spotlight without whom that
person in the spotlight would never be there.
And so I wanted to tell those people's stories.
Yeah.
So that was criteria one,
right?
They had to be,
they had to be unknown criteria too.
They had to be important.
Um,
it,
I the plenty of unknowns who don't do anything important.
Um,
and then the,
the third criteria was they had to be really,
really interesting people for just what I was talking about earlier.
This,
this is a book for a general audience.
I,
it's,
it's a,
it's a bunch of stories in addition to having these sort of broader themes and
it's,
it's underpinned by a hundred pages of notes at the back.
It's like a very deeply researched,
I have a phd in history kind of book,
but it's all buried super duper deep so that the stories can come up.
And if that's what you're trying to do,
you have to have really interesting people to talk about.
So that's how I chose the time.
That's how I chose the people.
Oh,
thank you.
I won't ask you who that COO.
I'm guessing that's not good.
I would not tell.
So let's,
so to introduce Mike Markkula so,
well let's maybe briefly introduce the other characters.
Maybe I can read them out and you sort of give us a couple of minor on why,
why Bob Taylor at um,
first of the Pentagon and then Xerox Parc.
Yeah.
So Bob Taylor is probably the person in the book who has the widest gap between
how important what he did was and how unknown he is.
Bob Taylor is the guy who convinced the department of Defense to start what
today we call the Internet to start the arpanet.
Then he,
after that,
went to Xerox Park where he ran that lab that came up with all of the components
with their sister lab.
Uh,
the system science lab was the s the sister lab,
um,
that came up with all the components of the modern personal computer,
kind of put them together.
That's the place that with first had the overlapping windows and wizzy wig.
And,
and you know,
the,
the mouse first in place by,
in,
by 1977,
this lab had the ability to have someone in Miami.
I saw a demo of this and knocked my socks off.
Someone in Miami controlling the cursor on the screen of someone in Palo Alto in
1977.
So Taylor round that lab,
that's the lab that Steve Jobs famously visited in 1979 and saw this in action
and said,
hmm,
I want that for apple.
And it moved into the Lisa and then later into the Mac and a Taylor ran this lab
with,
uh,
he had a master's degree in psychology and was running this lab that was so full
of brilliant phd computer scientist that the president of MIT worried allowed
the,
the future of computer science education in the United States was questionable
because everyone great was working for Bob Taylor.
That includes Eric Schmidt of Google,
worked for Taylor,
the cofounders of the Adobe [inaudible] and Warnock worked for Taylor Charles
Simonyi who went on to do the office suite at Microsoft,
worked for Taylor,
uh,
Larry Tesler who's key at APP.
I mean,
you can just go on and on.
Alan Kay was brought to Xerox Parc by Bob Taylor's.
So,
um,
this incredibly important guy.
No one,
no one knows what he did.
Oh.
And then he went onto deck and um,
where they were,
they had alta vista.
One of his researchers was the key guy behind Altavista,
you know,
many years before.
Google was a glimmer in anyone's eye.
So super important.
Yeah.
Al Alcorn.
Al Alcorn,
Al Al Al cording was the designer of a poem,
the first,
uh,
huge video game,
for Atari and a really interesting guy because he is an engineer engineer's an
engineer.
And a,
I really wanted to be sure to capture the stories of people who are heads down
doing the engineering.
Um,
but again,
fascinating guy,
you know,
had a picture of Lyndon Johnson on his wall in the late sixties and used him for
target practice and very interesting guy,
Fama Alvarez enrollment a fallen Alvarez a is someone when the book opens,
she's 12 years old and she is,
uh,
picking fruit in the orchards that used to be all over silicon,
silicon valley.
It was called the Valley of the heart's delight.
And she is doing this in the bucolic haven of Cupertino,
California.
And she goes on,
she doesn't go to college,
but she gets a job on the manufacturing line at Rome.
Something that most people don't know about a silicon valley is that this used
to be a manufacturing economy.
There were factories here they were,
they were called fabs.
But if they were here and they were,
uh,
they anchored the economy,
and there were plenty of very,
very good middle class jobs for people who,
uh,
didn't have an education behind a high school degree,
beyond a high school degree.
Excuse me.
And,
uh,
I wanted her story to be there because a,
she illuminates that sort of transition from the orchards to manufacturing.
And then she keeps going,
um,
and ends up as essentially the chief of staff to the president of IBM Rome.
And,
um,
as Rome itself is moving all of its manufacturing out of the area and she moves
much more into the kind of silicon valley jobs that we think of today.
These next two are sort of a paired with Niels Niels reamers of Stanford's
Office of Technology Licensing and Bob Swanson of Genentech.
Right.
So this,
this,
this is the story of the biotech industry.
I mean,
something that,
it took me six years to write this book and part of the reason it did was that
it's basically six books in one book.
Um,
so Neil's Ramers is the guy who started Stanford's Office of Technology
Licensing.
Uh,
when he got to Stanford,
uh,
he saw in 1970 he saw that,
the office of tech that Stanford's entire,
uh,
income from the inventions of all of its faculty,
staff and students for the previous 13 years had been $3,000 combined,
about 260 bucks a year.
He decided that didn't make any sense.
He decided to try to start something and he was not a high powered high level
guy who sort of a a mid level staffer.
Um,
and not an attorney either.
And he started the office,
um,
that to date has brought $2 billion into Stanford.
And that office is the reason that Stanford had a stake in Google's search
algorithm and had a nice chunk of equity and Google similar for Vm VM ware.
It's another big one out of Stanford.
Um,
the office of technology licensing and this particular,
this talks about their first really big hit,
which was the patent for recombinant DNA.
The whole notion of patenting,
um,
this,
this process was a radical one.
He faced a lot of challenges and I'm,
one of the people he worked closely with from early on was Bob Swanson,
who's the cofounder of Janine Tech and um,
someone who he had been an associate partner.
He was like a rocket ship superstar guy takes a chance and becomes an associate
partner.
One of the first ones,
maybe the first one,
I'm not sure.
I'm at Kleiner,
Kleiner Perkins Caufield and Byers,
um,
gets fired and decides,
I mean,
it was really rocked back on his heels and decides that he really believes in
this thing he's read about,
which is recombinant DNA is read about it in science magazine.
Can't find anyone to help him start this company,
ends up going on welfare to while he tries to figure it out.
It's very much of a sort of JK Rowling type story and um,
ended up launching a Genentech.
Unbelievable.
Yeah,
that's a great story.
Sandi.
Cursing.
Yeah.
Founder and CEO of ass computer.
Right.
So Sandy,
Kurt's Sig,
uh,
is the first woman to take a tech company public.
She started a software company called [inaudible] in 1972 and I wanted to write
about Sandy.
Um,
primarily because I wanted to write about software.
Uh,
this is the first time,
not just her company,
but this is the time when I'm in,
in the wake of an IBM consent decree.
Software and hardware unbundled from each other.
And so you get these independent little bitty software companies coming up.
This was silicon valley at a time when I just said they were building things.
It was a hardware place.
And even Larry Ellison who started oracle at around this exact same time talked
about how he couldn't give,
get anyone to pay attention to his entreaties to give him money to start a
software company.
He said that people would,
the venture capitals just laughed him out of the office.
And so sandy was interesting to me because she's an outsider because she's doing
software and she's an outsider because she's a woman.
So,
uh,
people literally think when she said she's selling software,
that she's selling lingerie.
And so,
um,
her story,
she's someone who comes up kind of outside of these famed networks that,
that other people that like Mike Markkula was able to bring apple into.
If you look at Apple's s one at their IPO,
almost every single senior exec plus they're a funders,
all had ties through mark [inaudible] to the semiconductor industry,
not the case for sandy curtsying.
She bootstrapped it from her kitchen table and,
um,
HP gave them time on their computers late,
late at night.
That was sort of her as close as she came to tapping into this network.
And again,
was a story I wanted to pull out because HP now has really diminished in
people's understanding of its importance.
But they brought up so many dozens of these little software companies couldn't
afford computers.
They were hundreds of thousands of dollars.
How could you possibly afford one of those?
But you could go in after hours at HP,
literally,
you could bring a sleeping bag and sleep on a floor in the closet and use their
computers to try to debug your code.
So it was,
it was an exciting story too.
Yeah,
that's great.
Arguably one of the earliest,
uh,
independent software vendors as they used to be known or ISV.
Yeah,
exactly.
In the applications business.
It's funny we've gone back to that.
That's how they talked about themselves
then.
Indeed.
So,
um,
with your background in history and you note there's five major industries in
seven years,
between 1969 and 1976 that are born,
they are the personal computing,
video games,
biotech,
modern venture capital and advanced semiconductor industries.
As you look back and other other times in history,
has there ever been another time like this in terms of the kind of
inventiveness,
how does it,
I didn't come up with anything that was really comparable in terms of the
breadth and impact.
I mean that is just when you look at where we are today,
it's,
you can trace so much of it back to this tiny little place and this little
period of time.
And I think that to me it was unrivaled and actually points to,
one of the things that I always think is so interesting about silicon valley,
which is that this has been the of so many different things.
In this case,
I'm talking about one generation,
but you know,
people always want to understand,
people come to Stanford all the time.
Why did Silicon Valley gets started here?
But to me a much more interesting question is why is Silicon Valley still going?
I mean,
Hewlett Packard started in 1939,
why is it still going and why have there been so many different generations of
technology that have come out of this place?
Because I mean,
you start with HP and with instrumentation and then you're into the chips and
then you're into the sort of the stuff I'm talking about consumer electronics
and biotech,
and then you're into networking and then you leave.
You can just kind of keep going forward.
And then,
you know,
we're in cloud and mobile and search and cars or your,
it's just,
and so how you,
how did all that happen?
And I think that,
um,
one of the,
I always point to two things actually.
I mean,
one is the,
the uh,
role of people doing what Mike Markkula did in this book.
Um,
when,
when jobs,
uh,
spoke at Stanford in 2005,
he talked about when he was fired from apple and how the first thing he did was
pick up the phone and call Bob Noyce,
who's the subject of my first book in a Co founder of Intel,
um,
and David Packard.
And he said that he appalled jobs that I apologized for dropping the baton and
he had this sense of sort of this relay race across time,
you know,
generation to generation handing off the baton.
And I think that's been such an important part of silicon valley history.
And I think that,
um,
in some sense,
you know,
part of what I hope this book can serve as is a baton pass,
sort of like,
well,
here's how this generation did it.
And then the second thing that I always point to is how important immigrants
have been to the rise of Silicon Valley.
It's a basically in the time that I'm writing about,
we're still,
people are coming here from other parts of the world.
I mean from other parts of the United States at an insane rate.
Uh,
just,
it was if a new person moved into silicon valley every half hour for 20 years
straight and no one moved out.
I mean that's the pace at which people were coming into the valley,
mostly from other parts of the country.
Now they come from all over the world,
but the effect has been exactly the same,
which is this constant refresh into the system of new ideas,
the best and brightest,
and very often the biggest risk takers.
Because I mean what it takes to pick up and leave,
leave your,
your country,
often your language,
your family,
your home for,
you know,
to try to do something really different is so important.
And at this point we've got two thirds of the people working in science and tech
in silicon valley are born outside of the United States.
So that's been another sort of secret to the,
to the valley's success.
And I think that while I can't see,
you know,
a comparable time period,
um,
for this book,
I feel like in some ways it was almost like the firing gun for everything that
has come since.
Yeah,
that's great.
Maybe that's a good,
good a place to ask you to read an excerpt.
Um,
and set the scene.
A bunch of us live in Silicon Valley here and you mentioned the orchards and
manufacturing.
Um,
I'd love to ask you to read a passage from the book that maybe gives us a sense
of what it was like at the end of the sixties,
early seventies.
And,
and you know what that's from a formative period was like,
if,
if you don't mind,
great.
We talked about this in advanced,
so I haven't marked,
um,
yeah,
so this as,
so the way the book is organized I should explain is it has what I think of as
core samples.
It's different time periods.
So it's,
I've got all of these seven people.
One way you could have done this book is talking about person a,
here's what they were doing,
1969,
we're going to follow them all the way through.
Now we're going to move our person B all the way through.
That to me was going to lose the magic of the story,
which is that these people's lives,
they just keep kind of overlapping.
I mean,
you just like Don Valentine shows up again and again and again.
And he had Larry Cincy me,
he's here and he's here and he's here at Regis Mckenna.
They just the same people.
And so I wanted to make sure in order,
venture capitalists,
attorney,
a Pr Guy,
uh,
the best in the business,
all of them.
Um,
I wanted to find a way to overlap those stories.
So I,
I tell where everyone is in each time period and I start those time periods with
a sort of,
you are here,
this is what silicon valley was like at this time.
So this is,
since this is for that sort of 1972 to 75 time period.
Um,
and it says,
I'll just read you it.
Uh,
in 1971,
a hard drinking reporter named Don Heffler published a three part history of the
men money and litigation behind the semiconductor business.
He titled The series,
which appeared in an industry newsletter called electronic news,
Silicon Valley USA.
It was the first formal use of a name that had for years been bandied about
inside the valley.
No one was beyond the readers of electronic news took notice of the new
technology reason that had been born on the San Francisco Peninsula.
Individual companies have begun to attract outside interests.
So Intel had it's IPO and that same year,
1971,
but it would be three years before any major national publication wrote about
the peninsula as a distinct technology based region.
It years would pass before the name is silicon valley gained widespread use.
And it's actually really funny.
All the other names that people came up with is like silicon gulch semiconductor
country semiconductor country's pretty good.
Uh,
in the early 1970s,
silicon valley startup companies were largely deemed irrelevant to the real
business of the United States,
which was concentrated in east coast financial centers in cities such as Detroit
and Pittsburgh and Chicago that had a manufacturing at their core,
the nation's new mini computer companies.
These were kind of the hot thing that everyone knew about were all clustered
around MIT and Harvard along Boston's route one 28 and stay okay.
So here's what was going on.
Stanford's reputation was on the rise,
which we know because it was beginning to be called the Harvard of the West.
Um,
but still the university attracted mostly students from California.
San Francisco was best known for its hippies.
Palo Alto was fighting its reputation as quote the peninsulas largest sex shops
center,
thanks to an eight block stretch of El Camino rail near the city southern border
that was home to multiple adult bookstores,
an x rated movie theater and a massage and massage parlors with names such as
the streaker and the foxy lady.
This is down the street from my first house.
Actually none of this pointed to a promising future as an economic powerhouse.
The rest of the business world might not have noticed,
but inside silicon valley,
things were brewing in 1972 the previous year until had invented the
microprocessor,
the chip that would soon nessel at the heart of consumer electronics such as the
personal computer and video games.
Meanwhile,
Hewlett Packard became the first silicon valley company to discover that an
advanced electronic device could have broad consumer appeal.
In 1972 the company introduced the HP 35 the world's first handheld calculator
that could do more than add,
subtract,
multiply and divide.
HP sold more than a hundred thousand in the first year despite a $400 price tag,
which is a very significant price bag.
This was my favorite part,
a cheeky chapter called shirt pocket power in the owner's manual noted.
We,
we thought you'd like to have something only fictional heroes like James Bond,
Walter Mitty or Dick Tracy are supposed to own for a pocket calculator.
I just love that.
Um,
for the most part,
these developments within silicon valley happened independently of one another,
but like different streams that feed a swift moving river,
the work would student begin to blend and swirled together.
The resulting network of personal and institutional connections would form the
foundation of today's silicon valley and the high technology revolution.
So that's sort of like,
that's where we were,
you know,
and,
and look,
look where we are now.
A little bit different for those of you that live in the area,
a little different,
a picture of the local environment,
uh,
back in the early seventies.
Yeah.
And especially people looking at the valley from the east coast.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing.
Um,
in the book you mainly see this because Xerox is,
is headquartered on the east coast and they're,
so they're looking at these crazies in Palo Alto who,
I mean,
this is a company who makes,
almost all of their profits came from the paper that they sold with the xerox
machines.
And here they've got this,
this research lab that's gone completely rogue and is trying to figure out how
do we even,
how do we start doing all the important stuff before it ever even hits the paper
and their descriptions of Xerox,
of Xerox Park and this area are hilarious.
I mean they're just sort of like everyone eats tofu there.
People Jog,
you know,
I mean it's just,
it's just,
it's,
it's amazing to see,
um,
how suspicious people were.
You know,
I mean they were watching the television,
they were seeing what was going on in San Francisco and you know,
people,
these protests in Berkeley and cause the Vietnam war is just an ad.
Its height had a huge implication for what happened here because so many people
who would have gone,
if you think that people were a graphics expert at this time,
what were you going to do?
You were going to go work for the Department of Defense almost certainly,
or maybe a subcontractor,
but all the sudden you have these people coming out of school and they don't
want anything to do with the dod.
They don't want anything to do with the war that's happening.
And that is to the gain of places like Xerox Parc and Atari and you know,
eventually apple.
This,
the,
the Silicon Valley's history really too often for my money is told in total
isolation from what's going on in the rest of the country,
much less the rest of the world.
And so this is a great example of why it,
why it mattered.
Who would've thought that would've been a consequence of the Vietnam war?
But it really was
all the interleaving affects that lead to these different companies.
It's amazing to think about,
um,
since you mentioned the Xerox Parc,
I've always been fascinated with their history.
So many,
uh,
so many core technological inventions came from there and from the assemblage of
amazing talent that Bob Taylor brought together,
yet they failed to commercialize those inventions.
And so I'm curious,
what's your perspective on why did Xerox Fail?
Was it,
was it some of this,
this skepticism towards Silicon Valley and the West Coast?
And also,
how did Bob Taylor think about that?
Was he troubled by,
um,
the fact that Xerox never reap the benefits of the,
of the inventions that,
uh,
that came from,
from his operation?
Yeah.
So I mean,
this is called a fumbling.
The future is the term everyone uses for a very nasty book about Xerox.
Xerox fumbled the future because the argument goes,
apple could have been xerox's,
Adobe could have been xerox's Microsoft and you know,
certainly everything that followed in the wake of windows could have,
could have to xerox.
Um,
so that's the argument hadn't Allen's question is how did,
how did Xerox fumbled the future?
Um,
so xerox would very quickly point out we did not fumble the future.
the printer,
the laser printer is another thing that was in print invented add xerox parc
again with,
with basically with a refugee from a different part of Xerox who had this idea
to do this and they didn't want to do it.
And Taylor's like,
come,
come to us,
we will help you do this.
Um,
so xerox commercialized the laser printer and made back way more money than they
ever spent on Xerox Park.
So they would completely say that as irrelevant question and it makes perfect
sense that a company whose entire business model ran on paper would actually
commercialize the one thing that came out of this place that used up paper.
Right.
Which was a printer.
So,
um,
they would,
they would object to that,
uh,
for sure.
And with some,
some legitimacy.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
they,
no one in the world could hold on to the talent and ideas that were coming out
of that place.
This is silicon valley has these places.
So the first one was Fairchild semiconductor,
which was just with this incredible compression.
Is there like a of of brilliance,
right?
So you look at the eight founders of Fairchild and among them are Bob Noyce who
co-invented the microchip and his partner,
Gordon Moore,
who goes on to start Intel with him.
And Eugene Kleiner who starts Kleiner Perkins and John Air Knee,
who invents the planar process,
which is underpinning still chip manufacturing today.
And you just keep going.
I mean,
the people who worked at Fairchild in include Don Valentine,
Charlie's spork,
the companies that came out of it or Intel,
AMD national.
I mean you can just kind of keep going.
Well,
I mean that company just went ooh.
And it was like the seed pods kind of scattering its seeds all over the area
that then became the chip industry.
Xerox Parc was another one of those places in more recent memory.
Paypal's another one of those places that just sort of does great things when
it's together.
And then the founders and the key employees kind of go on to populate what
happens next and this and this.
It just happens.
I what happens,
so Taylor could not have given a darn about,
um,
whether his stuff got commercialized.
He really felt,
he believed that the main interesting thing in this world was research.
If you want to waste your time on marketing and lawyers and money and finances,
fine with him.
But he didn't care.
I mean,
I asked him once about the money that he made because,
I just told you all the people who came from his company and they all,
well,
they all loved him.
He undoubtedly had the ability invest in all of the companies I just laid out on
the ground floor.
And he had so little interest in money that he started talking about his 401k
plan.
Like he didn't get what I was talking about.
That just didn't,
isn't what kind of floated his boat.
But when it,
when his people started leaving because people,
engineers and these computer scientists,
they don't want to build something that gets buried and no one ever uses it when
they know it's incredible.
They want it.
And when,
when his people started leaving,
then he lost it.
He was furious.
He was so angry.
Um,
that's so,
yeah.
Yeah.
No,
I think really one of the,
like the world's great research labs,
um,
and,
uh,
some things never change,
right?
Engineers want their products used by not only millions these days,
but the billions possible with the internet.
So,
and a number of the sort of gray beards even now at,
at Google who are just sort of doing the research.
I,
those are,
those are tailored,
they worked for Bob tailored.
Bob had a,
he hosted a tomato fest in his yard every year
and it was
like,
here come the Turing award winners and here comes,
you know,
like a major mind buying Google translate and here,
here they are,
they're all just kind of descending into his backyard.
It was incredible.
It's like a magnet,
you know?
Huh.
For talent.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
so I wanna I wanna ask you about the two women that you profile and obviously a
lot of talk these days about women in Silicon Valley underrepresentation.
Um,
I'd love to ask you,
what's the same and what has changed from earlier times,
uh,
about being a woman in tech and in Silicon Valley from your perspective?
Yeah,
I appreciate that question.
Being asked in that same versus different as opposed to better versus worse.
Um,
because that's a really tough question to answer.
So,
um,
I would say it,
it has never been easy for women in,
in tech,
in silicon valley,
but for different reasons now than then.
So,
um,
the things that the women in my book had to put up with,
and I interviewed a number of women because the women were there.
I mean they were designing the video games,
they were programming the computers.
They were really like inventing the icons on the Mac,
but,
um,
they were not brought to the surface at all in,
in a lot of these stories.
So I talked to a lot more women than are just in the book who are hitting,
you know,
the subject of the book and the things that they faced I would make would curl
your hair.
I mean,
I can't even,
it's one of those things where like I can't speak about this in front of a
family friendly audience and I didn't actually put a lot of it in the book.
Um,
but there are things that I put in the book like,
uh,
the literally pornographic short story that Atari published written by one of
its in the company newsletter.
And,
um,
just,
you know,
hot tub parties that the board meetings were held in hot tubs.
I mean,
it's very,
very,
um,
behavior that in some ways looks super familiar to the worst stories we're
hearing now.
Um,
but what's really was really hard for me to get my mind around really hard is
that this was happening at a time when the surrounding culture was so different
in a lot of ways from how it is now.
So I mean,
in the,
in the mid seventies,
I was 1974,
1975 before a woman,
a married woman could just get a credit card in her own name without her,
you know,
her husband's permission.
And it was 1980 before the EOC recognized sexual harassment in the workplace.
And so the overriding culture was such that when,
like when IBM showed women using computers,
which they did,
and their sort of their flagship,
um,
offices in New York,
the women doing the work because it was their job,
we're told that they were being put in the window because then it would be clear
to men that this was easy to do.
And,
um,
the women I talked to [inaudible]
okay.
I would say that with such explicit sexual harassment,
I can't believe the things that these people said and did and they'd say,
oh no,
that was just so and so.
He's a jerk or,
you know,
then,
everyone was doing that.
And so it's,
it's,
so was it,
was it harder for them?
I don't know,
because the expectations were so different and these surroundings were so
different.
It really was a,
a tough,
you can hear from the women talking about it now.
It's still kind of hard for me to get my mind around.
Um,
Sandy Kurt Sig said that it's Amy Kurtz curtsying who was mistaken for a booth
bay because she was very beautiful and told to,
you know,
get coffee for people when she was the CEO that they were trying to sell to.
Um,
you know,
she said that the fact that she was the boss made all the difference in the
world,
right?
She,
she was calling the shots.
And so,
I mean,
I think that sort of speaks to something that a lot of people are talking about
now with being,
you know,
one of the possible among them,
the constellation of many solutions,
we have to come up with them.
Leadership.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
And I think,
I mean,
kind of getting back to that baton pass image of Steve Jobs,
the question of,
okay,
how do we make sure they're a whole lot of Bhutan's going all at once and that
they're being handed off,
not just to the usual suspects and you know,
not just to the person who,
you know,
you,
you wrote for the Stanford Review with,
but you know,
other people.
How did,
how has that all going to work out and,
and it's kind of incumbent on us to,
to figure that out.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great perspective.
Um,
so the titles,
troublemakers,
why that title?
What's the,
um,
what's the common,
attribute perhaps that all of these seven people have in terms of the trouble
that they're creating at this formative time?
Yeah,
titles are incredibly hard to come up with,
I have to say.
Um,
we had this one,
then we went to some other ones that never quite sat right,
came back to this one.
So the source of it is,
um,
actually it's,
it's another,
I guess Steve Jobs story when he comes back to apple in 1996 and then they bring
out the,
yeah,
add the next year that,
um,
it's,
you know,
here's to the crazy ones,
the troublemakers,
the square pegs in round holes or however it goes.
It's in the front of the book.
Um,
and that really captured to me the essence of what these people were doing,
which is,
okay,
one title we considered was disruptors,
which is,
I'm really glad we didn't go with,
um,
but there wasn't there,
there was the notion at this time that to do what you needed to do,
you couldn't do it inside the existing boundaries.
That kind of constrains you,
but there wasn't the notion of,
I'm just going to blow this up for no reason.
Um,
it was much more sort of,
I want to accomplish this thing.
Um,
and here's how I'm,
I,
I have to do it,
you know,
like,
um,
yeah,
that's so Sandy,
Kurt Sig,
you know,
she couldn't get money from anyone.
She had to get it from her dad.
She was,
it wasn't,
it wasn't some sort of a,
I'm going to stick it to the banks kind of idea,
you know,
um,
or,
uh,
like the whole notion of dressing casually.
Why is it that none of us is in a suit right now?
Well,
that wasn't some sort of stick it to the man.
You know,
I,
I don't want to be constrained by sort of the,
the ideals of,
of a broader society.
It was that all of these people were,
most of them are coming straight out of college.
A lot of them were starting companies straight out of college and they just
started out in jeans and kept going.
Or they were these computer scientists who couldn't get time on computers except
late at night.
And so that's a big part of where the,
uh,
casual work hours came from too,
was that it was just,
it just sort of naturally flowed out of the academic world that surrounded
people and the kind of Loosey Goosey counterculture feature.
And in terms of what these three these people had in common,
um,
okay.
I would say,
They had an unusual set of characteristics in common.
One was they were simultaneously,
they were audacious and they were persistent.
And sometimes those two don't go together.
You'll have the people who have sort of the big out there idea.
But um,
and Bob Noyce was one of these people big out there idea and then he to go on
and find the next big out there idea and Gordon Moore's behind him.
Like,
okay,
well that's a good one.
That's a bad idea.
You know,
these people tended almost to a person to be able to have the big idea and to
follow through on the big idea or to find people who could follow through.
So that audacity and persistence.
And I think the third feature that I would point to is an appreciation of,
of the team.
Um,
none of these people set out to be or saw themselves as an independent rock star
kind of doing this,
um,
for the adoring acolytes who are their employees.
I mean this was very much of a sense that,
um,
we're all in this together and I,
I think those three cover a lot because they're a ancillary characteristics that
I'm the kind of fallout,
right.
Lamar are pretty significant.
Yeah.
Um,
so you talked about passing the baton and other industries sort of benefiting
from each other and the semiconductor industry sort of in the backdrop plays a
very big part and a lot of these companies,
a lot of the talent,
Mike Markkula one example then going to apple,
but other examples like that.
What was it about the experience,
that early experience in semiconductor industry that set these individuals up to
become such great technologists and,
and executives in these,
in these other industries?
Yeah.
So I mean I think that what the chip industry gave people was,
um,
a sort of understanding of at that time how this worked for a very complicated
idea to become a business.
I think also the infrastructure that was built up to support chip entrepreneurs
turned out to be the exact same infrastructure that these consumer electronics
companies plugged into that then biotech plugged into that still,
I mean,
think of how important sequoia is to this day.
people are still plugging into these same networks that were set up.
I think that's something that the semiconductor industry,
um,
couldn't help with was figuring out how to sell to consumers.
So on Nina,
as you know,
apple,
apple almost died right in the period that that jobs was gone.
And I think that they didn't,
they didn't have anyone there who really knew how to sell to consumers.
And I mean,
one of the things that's really interesting to me is they bring in John Sculley
and everyone laughs,
oh my God,
this Pepsi Co Guy,
you know,
he,
what's,
what's he doing?
But what they were trying to do is figure out how the heck do you sell to,
how do you sell to a consumer.
I mean,
this is something,
so the chip industry was vitally important on one level and on some level this
generation had to get beyond the one that came before.
And that's just,
that's just the way it works.
I mean that's the example I always use is of a grain of sand in a pearl.
And how,
you know,
you can have those sort of chips at the center of this little grain there,
but then you build these layers around it and around it.
And that again,
those generations that I'm talking about.
So now we're out here and it's very easy to,
you know,
we're out where we are in this part.
This is a very big pearl.
Um,
and we're,
it's hard to imagine that.
Yeah.
Back Down at the core,
we're still dealing with those chips cause so much have been added to it.
So you do,
you have,
you lean on it,
but you've got to move beyond it.
Yeah.
That's great.
How,
um,
so love to ask you,
there's so many different great personalities profile in the book.
If you had the opportunity to work with one of them and their prime,
who would it be?
Oh,
okay.
Um,
if I had the opportunity to work with as a peer,
one of them,
it would be fawn Alvarez because she is a firecracker and hilarious and I
really,
really liked her.
Uh,
I would have loved to work for Bob Taylor if he liked me.
I would not have wanted him to work for me.
He was a very difficult man to have work for you.
Um,
and um,
but he created an environment and everyone who worked for him who loved him
talks about this sort of protected world that he created for innovation and
creativity and execution.
That I think just would have been magnificent to be a part of.
Sounds like if he didn't like you,
it wasn't quite as you were pleasant.
They were gone.
You were gone.
Yeah.
Oh,
interesting.
And so,
um,
we'll open up for questions just a minute.
Um,
my,
uh,
my last question will be sort of turning to some of the high tech companies
today.
Um,
lots of the,
the world's most valuable companies these days are in high tech.
Um,
and so I'm,
I'm curious what companies like Google,
Amazon,
Facebook,
name,
your favorites,
um,
have learned from these predecessors.
What are the,
what's the foundation that they're standing on that you think should be
recognized or,
or maybe hasn't been recognized as much and should be,
uh,
as,
as we all grow up?
Well,
I mean,
something that I think,
um,
has been really interesting,
that seems to still be embedded in the DNA in a lot of these companies.
Is the founder continuing on whether he or she or it's usually they,
the lone founder concept is,
it's just a myth.
Um,
almost all great companies are founded by at least two people and sometimes
more.
Um,
the,
but none the less that the founders have stuck around,
even when the sort of soup adult supervision comes in.
I think that has been a lesson that has been learned from watching these,
these companies where founders haven't stuck around.
And it's problematic I think to
all of the things that people associate with silicon valley perks now.
Like a broad distribution of stock options is a great example.
Um,
even a lot of,
uh,
things like free lunch,
um,
sports being,
you know,
sporting equipment and stuff happening on campus.
A lot of that cultural stuff came directly from this time period that I'm
talking about.
This company Rome where fallen Alvarez worked,
which is now a parking lot at the 40 niners stadium.
Um,
that company was incredible.
I mean,
they,
they had jogging paths and uh,
they had a three month sabbatical,
three month paid sabbatical after seven years of work.
And I mean,
all of these sorts of benefits that I'm talking about speak to what I think
companies have really learned in the valley,
which is that the,
the people are the,
the easy,
most easily lost and the most valuable part of a company.
Um,
and that I think,
again,
it's something that's been embedded in the DNA for a long time at this point.
Yeah,
that's a great,
great point.
All right,
up to your questions.
We have a mic on the side.
Please don't be bashful.
Hi.
I really enjoyed reading the book.
The title is perfect.
Thank you.
And I have a question related to the last one about a common thread through many
of the stories,
it seems to be that one story that repeated over and over is a large
organization or a group of people either failing to see the value in some new
opportunity or being unwilling to recognize you're going to be in staff.
This case,
you know,
Warner with Atari,
Stanford with these patents,
uh,
HP,
like you mentioned before with apple,
this pattern seems to repeat over and over again.
The stories increase the opportunity for as a trouble maker.
So in the context of today,
if you have a new set of large,
powerful organizations,
they're clearly done something.
I'm curious whether they've managed to sort of subsume the trouble makers.
Is there something structurally different now or is it inevitable that today's
powerful organizations and institutions?
We'll miss the next big valuable opportunity,
just like you've described in your book.
Okay.
So,
um,
we'll let,
we'll today's big companies be able to avoid the fate of,
um,
you know,
the classic,
it's the innovator's dilemma is clay Christianson puts it right.
Um,
so a lot of people would say that the big companies today are trying to avoid
this by acquiring all the small companies,
um,
which there's some real debate as to whether that's a to silicon valley's
future.
I,
if all of the small companies get eaten up by the big ones,
um,
well,
it's a legitimate question to ask actually.
Uh,
but there's,
there's no,
there isn't no way that great companies aren't coming out of these big companies
and,
and won't continue to do.
So.
I mean,
I think that the other thing that software,
the,
that's so much of this innovation happening in software has done because it's
decreased the capital requirements so much and because it's made it possible for
people to work in lots of places that are not all silicon valley.
Um,
is the,
the question of where else are these ideas going to be coming from?
Because you,
you know,
so many of these companies that come out of bigger companies come because there
are a couple of usually engineers who can't get something done at their big
company and they decide to go off and do it themselves.
And those people are finding each other in other ways now,
which I think is interesting.
Uh,
I don't think that Silicon Valley has obsoleted itself by making location
unimportant.
Like I think that the serendipity factor of just sort of being able to walk down
the street or,
I mean we met in our daughter's kindergarten class is a million years ago.
Um,
there's,
there's no,
there's no replacing that.
Like I don't worry,
uh,
for Silicon Valley's future or the future of innovation at all.
I just think that the way that I described there being multiple streams that can
feed it,
I think those streams now have their origin points to the way you know,
in various places all over the world.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man,
it's been a related,
uh,
thinking,
the like small companies being consumed by larger ones.
Um,
I don Norman came and talked to at Google about a year ago and afterwards,
like there was a great discussion around,
um,
so you talked about places like Xerox Parc and these wonderful innovation
centers and even before that or around that time about labs and kind of Bemoan
the fact that you didn't know if that was the case.
Nowadays,
if you have spaces like that,
um,
maybe you do have spaces like that.
A lot of the times they're under the umbrella of a larger company.
And so thinking back to like passing the baton,
so there's been,
you know,
baton passes from big company or like from a place like maybe apple,
it's already a bigger company to another company.
Do you see,
like,
I'm wondering if like Xerox Parc do you think has passed the time to another
place that can provide this kind of exploratory environment,
that type of innovation that's maybe,
um,
well I guess it wasn't independent cause it was also attached to Xerox,
but yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean
this is sort of,
you know,
Google sponsors a bunch of moon launchy project kinds of things.
Right?
I mean,
I think that's something that we see people being interested in at the big
companies.
I also,
I'm an,
I was on a panel with a,
an early hacker and someone asked a question similar to this and um,
so I'll just sort of pair it back what he said because I thought it was
interesting,
not something I really know about.
He was talking about all the maker spaces and the hacker spaces and the,
uh,
ability of people to do real innovation without needing the underlying
infrastructure of a big company to sponsor the work.
Now the question of,
you know,
what can that impact be?
Um,
I don't know.
Yeah.
One of the first articles I wrote for the New York Times was about,
um,
a guy who had hacked Johnny Chung Lee,
who had hacked a wee and then turned it into a very cheap whiteboard for
schools.
And how the way he got that invention out there,
uh,
was through youtube and how this had completely bypass the typical research
structure of,
um,
you know,
a person working alone in a,
or with a small team in an academic environment.
And then waiting forever to get your paper accepted somewhere for publication
and get it peer reviewed,
get it out.
There were like four people will read it.
And you know that this has created a completely new way to disseminate
information in the same way we've seen with Twitter and all of the other things
that have created this,
um,
mass explosion of,
of information.
Um,
and then he went on to go to Microsoft researchers is interesting and I think
he's moved on since then,
but so I think there are opportunities out there for sure.
I've heard a lot of people say that modern devices seems to be a lot less to
gribble and accurate and basic yourself.
Now it seems like the interaction,
you certain apps and to find ways,
so for the future talent pipeline,
uh,
how do we keep raising this next generation of light tinkerers who were reverse
engineering,
their electronics and so forth.
Yeah.
Uh,
and so I will say this has been a concern for a while.
Um,
the people even coming straight out of the,
well,
I mean,
honestly,
people were worried when,
uh,
we moved away from cars.
Like this is something that I really remember Bob Noyce had to talk to his
family about because,
well,
how,
you know,
you,
you can see how to take apart an engine,
but what about what these chips,
you know,
you can't do that with chips.
You can't do that with electronics.
So the,
the bar keeps getting,
um,
that said it's a legitimate question.
And I think that I th I think that
we're learning,
you know,
those,
those kids are learning,
uh,
the same kind of creativity within a differently defined set of limits.
And I don't,
I don't know the answer beyond,
I don't know the answer.
How do you crack those limits open further to kind of return to the level of
something more tangible?
Um,
but it's,
it's,
it is an important question because having the playgrounds so tightly defined by
other people is,
is troublesome,
you know?
Um,
I don't know how it's gonna play out.
I,
I think that a lot of people see real hope for sort of a freer internet.
I know you were talking on the device level,
but I mean on the broader level,
um,
in the blockchain as a,
uh,
as a sub place that has less control,
you know,
less of different spaces.
I don't know if there's,
we could come up with something analogous,
um,
beyond sort of typical open source stuff,
uh,
on a smaller level,
open source versus walled garden sort of debates.
Do you have any thoughts
blockchain because that was going to be over as the second question was going to
be your thoughts and cryptocurrencies.
Yeah,
I'm passing on my thoughts on cryptocurrencies.
I don't know enough.
Yeah,
sure.
Thank you very much.
And my question is just like a fault in CV,
the Sim conductor evolution.
Uh,
do you see,
uh,
Bobby but the seeds from silicon valley been implanted in other areas throughout
the world and we've got to be an interesting story for the book.
Yeah.
So absolutely.
I think that the circulation of people in and out of silicon valley from other
parts of the world is,
is completely,
uh,
bringing the model to other parts of the world and refining the model here in
the valley.
Um,
there's an interesting book,
it came out many years ago by a woman named Annalise Saxony and called the new
argonauts that talks about exactly this,
the,
the sort of people who come,
the sort of communities that are made by different immigrant groups and then
they go back.
Um,
and again,
I would really point to if silicon valley,
if the United States wants to hold on to its edge as an innovator,
we need to be doing what we can to make sure that people have an incentive to
stay here.
Uh,
I think another vector before I forget,
other than the entrepreneurs themselves is of course a lot of the venture
companies have built,
uh,
arms or offices around the world.
Um,
the one approach that I think is probably not going to work very well is
sometimes you see these top down government efforts in other parts of the world
to sort of force a silicon valley.
We're going to build a tech region and you know,
if you build it they will come.
That doesn't really seem to work.
Hello.
These CIF devalued the stories.
So one thing is,
is this cutting delivered up media companies like Facebook and Google
seems to be this kind of,
so an sp more at the beginning of time get it.
Cause you should not hear Dan Dan different that a strong independent journalism
seems to be not so much shit busy.
So
any comment on it
and it seems to be a bit awkward
stumbling through hot does that speed in this.
So,
uh,
okay.
I think I might
Take a little bit of issue with that premise.
I actually think there are a lot of entrepreneurs out there who are aspiring to
build great,
great companies for the long haul.
Uh,
I think that uh,
those aspirations can evaporate when someone offers enormous sums of money.
Um,
but I do think,
um,
the,
you know,
something that came through in this book again and again and again and again and
again and again is how hard it is to start a company,
how hard it is to get this off the ground.
Even with all the support that you have,
how many people are in your camp rooting for you.
You know,
how however great your network is,
it's super hard.
And I don't think anybody would ever make it through,
you know,
the sixth consecutive day of 20 hours of work if they were like,
some day someone else is going to run this all,
you know,
it's just not something that people aspire to.
I think as a group,
I think you can get very tired and money can look very good and it becomes
something you know,
you want.
But I think it's pretty,
it's pretty cynical.
Let's put it that way,
to start like,
sort of like,
my dream is to build an acquisition target.
You know,
um,
I really liked your analogy about the,
uh,
sort of like the seeds that spread like the pot of seeds.
Uh,
that's spreading.
And grow the next generation of companies.
So like paypal,
Mafia,
uh,
at Xerox Parc,
a Fairchild.
Uh,
I was curious,
is there like a common strain and how these groups form,
do you think they're just incredible individuals to sort of find each other or
do you think there's like a way of working together,
like a worldview that that's learned once they sort of come together,
um,
under some great leader or something like that?
Ah,
that's a superb question.
Um,
no,
the three examples I cited,
Fairchild Park and paypal a what,
what they have in common is that those people in every case knew each other
before they got there.
Uh,
so if anyone's read the new book,
Bro Topia,
which I think is a very interesting and good book.
Uh,
one of the things that it really points to is who gets left out when,
uh,
your only bringing into your culture,
people who,
um,
you know,
from a previous experience and there's really,
they're smart reasons to do that.
Namely,
you guys are all thinking similarly.
Like you get to skip the acculturation step because,
oh,
we all worked together at Shockley semiconductor,
let's go start Fairchild.
Or we all got contracts from,
uh,
Arpa under this guy,
Bob Taylor,
and we,
and he likes the way we think,
we like the way he thinks.
So we're all going to just come together,
start park,
or we were all in Stanford together.
Um,
sort of on the conservative paper and such.
I now,
except for Reid Hoffman who was kind of like their,
their foil,
um,
now let's all go and start paypal together.
Um,
so I mean that is something that they've had in common.
Google's an interesting counter example to that,
right?
Because a Google for example in included women early on,
um,
very early on,
people like,
well,
Jackie and Marissa,
my error and um,
Sheryl Sandberg,
right?
So that's a story of a different potential model than the,
we're all in sync.
Um,
and it,
it appears to have worked
along the lines of where you're talking about how these couples,
they for each time conductor,
they grow,
then they pop.
Right.
And just thinking right now,
I mean did dawn that companies that are in the area like Google,
Facebook,
apple,
like you're just taking,
we're just taking so much real estate all over the place.
Like I remember here,
it used to be so concrete,
I picks up five seat parlor.
We have,
uh,
I was with a company,
rob as you previously.
Now Google's taken all those campuses because if you see any dangers or concerns
that if Google were to off load hopefully,
but all this real estate that it controls like all of the land and all the
different buildings happen.
Wow.
So now we're getting into,
the beautiful thing about being a historian is you never have to predict the
future.
Um,
I,
I don't know,
I can tell you that in a previous one thing silicon valley history teaches quite
well is that great things happen in economic declines.
So,
um,
you know,
you don't have to have any customers to buy your stuff when you're starting the
company.
You're trying to get it going.
So all of a sudden office space would be cheaper.
You would have people who are highly trained but are not employed.
You have,
I think that you might see another flowering of innovation.
Scarcity breeds clarity.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's great.
Awesome.
Well,
Leslie,
thank you so much for sharing your incredible insight and providing perspective
on,
uh,
not only our industry,
but we're many of us live.
It's been fabulous to have you,
and we look forward to having you again at toxic goal.
Thank you very much.
It's my pleasure.